bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un sujet un peu différent de
d'habitude on va parler de sciences
économiques alors pas tellement pour en
évoquer les grands principes
d'autres le font déjà mieux que moi mais
pour vous raconter une petite anecdote
une anecdote qui nous dit des choses
intéressantes sur le fonctionnement de
la science et son utilisation pour des
décisions politiques
ça peut peut-être nous servir autrement
[Musique]
l'histoire commence en 2010 à ce moment
là on est en pleine crise économique et
financière celle qui a commencé quelques
années plus tôt et les gouvernements de
tous les pays se demandent logiquement
comment sortir rapidement et
efficacement de cette crise c'est alors
que deux économistes canettes groff et
carmen reinhart publie un article
scientifique qui va devenir extrêmement
influent ces deux là ne sont pas
n'importe qui
ce sont deux pointures de l'université
de harvard aux états unis et en plus de
ça ils publient leur article dans une
revue spécialisée
l'american economic review qui est une
des revues les plus prisées des
chercheurs en sciences économiques
on est donc a priori sur du lourd
l'article en question s'intitule growth
in time of state la croissance en temps
de dette
le but de l'article c'est d'analyser le
lien qui peut exister entre la
croissance économique d'un pays et son
niveau d'endettement
c'est à dire la dette publique accumulée
par l'état alors pour ça nos deux
chercheurs se basent sur les données
économiques depuis 1946 pour 20 pays
occidentaux les etats-unis la france le
portugal l'allemagne etc et ils essaient
de voir si en moyenne
il existe un lien entre croissance et
dette par la dette dont on parle ce
n'est pas le déficit du budget pour une
année donnée
c'est la dette accumulée au cours du
temps année après année et comme le
montant va dépendre évidemment de la
taille de l'économie du pays
on exprime généralement en pourcentage
du pib prenons un exemple le pib de
l'allemagne en 2018 c'était 3344
milliards d'euros et la dette cumulée
c'était 2070 milliards donc la dette
cumulée de l'allemagne valait environ 62
% de son pib alors comme c'est un cumul
des dettes de l'état qui s'est construit
année après année ça peut très bien
dépasser 100% du pib
il n'y a pas de contradiction logique en
italie par exemple on est actuellement
autour de 135 % du pib
bon donc nos deux économiste de harvard
collecte les valeurs de croissance et de
dettes pour chacun des vingt pays entre
1946 et 2009 on imagine qu'ils ont un
grand tableau avec tous ces chiffres et
ils cherchent à voir s'il ya un lien
entre les deux et pour ça ils produisent
l'analyse suivante
tout d'abord ils vont classé la dette en
4k pour chaque pays et chaque année soit
la dette est entre 0 et 30 % soit entre
30 et 60% entre 60 et 90% bien au-delà
de 90%
et il regarde la croissance moyenne
observée dans chacun de ces quatre cas
et voici ce qu'ils obtiennent
dans le premier cas quand on a une dette
en dessous de 30% on à 4,1 pour cent de
croissance en moyenne
dans le second cas 2 8% de croissance un
peu moins dans le troisième cas entre 60
et 90%
toujours 2 8% mais au-delà de 90% de
dettes bim pas de croissance du tout en
moyenne même une très légère récession
-0 1%
alors ça c'est très intéressant ça
montre que d'une part il y aurait un
lien entre dette et croissance
ce qui d'un point de vue économique
paraît tout à fait envisageable on peut
imaginer qu'à des niveaux de dette
élevée soit associé dé croissance plus
faible pourquoi pas mais surtout
l'analyse montre qu'il y a un effet de
seuil monstrueux avant 90 % de dette en
fait ça va mais au delà de 90 % de dette
la croissance chute brutalement il ya un
seuil fatidique
l'existence de ce seuil de 90% c'est le
principal message de cet article et du
fait de la réputation des auteurs et de
la revue dans laquelle l'article a été
publié
il a eu semble-t-il une influence très
importante sur les politiques
économiques qui ont été mises en oeuvre
à l'époque ça se passe en 2010 ça je
vous le rappelle derrière les
conclusions des deux économistes
il y a évidemment en filigrane l'idée
que malgré la crise il faudrait
absolument éviter que les dettes
publiques atteignent le seuil fatidique
de 90%
si l'on suit le raisonnement dépasser ce
seuil risquerait de tuer durablement la
croissance et tout devrait donc être
fait pour l'éviter notamment via des
politiques d'austérité financière de
rigueur budgétaire d'économies sur les
services publics etc
cette conclusion de l'article de ringard
et rogoff sur le seuil de 90%
on la retrouve à de nombreuses reprises
dans les débats économiques et
politiques qui ont existé à l'époque en
avril 2011 par exemple 40 sénateurs
américains ont auditionné les deux
économistes
et comme le montrent ces extraits les
débats ont tourné notamment autour du
fameux seuil de 90%
plus près de chez nous le commissaire
européen à l'économie olli rehn écrira
aux ministres des finances de l'union je
cite il est largement reconnu sur la
base de recherches sérieuses que quand
le niveau de dette publique atteint
environ 90%
il a tendance à avoir un effet négatif
sur le dit
miss mme de l'économie ce qui se traduit
par une faible croissance pendant
plusieurs années
le ministre des finances britannique
déclarait lui aussi à la même époque
les dernières recherches suggèrent
qu'une fois que la dette a dépassé
environ 90% du pib
les risques d'un impact négatif
important sur la croissance à long terme
deviennent très importants dans le monde
anglophone la conclusion de ringard et
rogoff a fait l'objet d'articles dans
dix économistes le new york times the
wall street journal le washington post
et c'est dans les milieux universitaires
l'article a eu aussi une influence
énorme
d'après le site google scholar il a été
cité à ce jour plus de 3300 fois dans
des travaux scientifiques alors le seul
souci de cette histoire vous l'avez
compris dès le titre de la vidéo c'est
que les conclusions de cet article si
influents se basait sur un calcul fait
avec excel calcul qui contenait une
grosse faute de frappe dans une des
formules l'histoire de la découverte de
cette erreur est assez intéressante elle
commence tardivement un trois ans plus
tard en 2013
quand un étudiant en économie tomasz
herndon a un devoir à faire
il étudie à l'université du
massachusetts à amherst pas très loin de
harvard et ses profs ont posé un
exercice en apparence classique prendre
un article économique de son choix et
essayer d'en reproduire les résultats
thomas sternum décide alors de choisir
l'article si influent de rhein art et
rob huff et commence à essayer de
trouver les données et refaire leur
analyse
mais impossible de reproduire leurs
conclusions il en parle à ses profs qui
lui disent que quand même ça devrait pas
être bien difficile les données sont
facilement disponibles
c'est juste faire des moyennes ça
devrait pas être bien dur mais n'ont
rien à faire ils ne trouvent pas les
mêmes chiffres que rhein art et rogoff
grâce au soutien de ses profs qui
commence aussi à avoir des doutes
notre étudiant écrit alors aux deux
pointures de harvard pour leur demander
les détails de leurs calculs rhein art
et rogoff envoie alors une feuille excel
contenant les données utilisées et
l'analyse qu'ils ont fait est là notre
étudiants découvrent trois problèmes
le premier c'est que les deux
économistes de la harvard ont calculé
les moyennes d'une façon assez bizarre
ça n'est pas mathématiquement faux mais
c'est assez étrange puisque ça donne des
poids différent à chaque pays d'une
façon qui est un peu aléatoire par
exemple avec leurs façons de faire les
moyennes certaines années de la nouvelle
zélande ont un impact énorme sur le
résultat bien plus important que paris
ample celle du royaume uni deuxième
problème les économistes de harvard
n'ont pas utilisé dans leur analyse
certaines données apparemment disponible
notamment celles qui concernaient le
canada la nouvelle-zélande et
l'australie avant 1950 des périodes
justement de forte croissance pour ces
pays
malgré une dette supérieure à 100%
difficile de savoir s'il s'agit d'un
oubli d'une exclusion justifier ou
carrément d'une magouille à aucun moment
dans leur article reinhart et rogoff non
mentionné ces exclusions et enfin
troisième problème le plus spectaculaire
il y avait une grosse boulette dans une
formule du fichier excel pour faire le
calcul final celui qui donne les
chiffres qui ont été publiés et que j'ai
mentionné rhein art et rogoff on fait
une moyenne qui oubliait complètement
l'australie l'autriche la belgique le
canada et le danemark
les cinq premiers pays par ordre
alphabétique la raison on la voit sur
cette capture d'écran du fichier excel
obtenu par le journaliste baïkal elle
montre clairement l'erreur une moyenne
qui ne porte que sur 15 pays parmi les
vingt probablement une formule pas mise
à jour ou bien mal à tirer sur les
cellules au total ce qu'a montré notre
étudiant et qui a été publiée dans un
article qu'il a écrit avec ses profs
c'est que si on corrige ses trois
erreurs le résultat change pratiquement
voici une comparaison avant après on a
donc le taux de croissance moyen dans
les quatre cas un one 30 % de dette 30
60 60 90 et au delà de 90 % pour les
trois premiers groupes
après correction on retrouve des
chiffres analogue à ce qu'avait reinhart
et rogoff 4,2 pour cent 3,1 pour cent et
3,2 pour cent mais pour le dernier
groupe les dettes
au-delà de 90% on trouve 2 2% de
croissance est pas moins 0 1% comme
affirmé initialement par les deux
auteurs de harvard
une sacrée différence quand même alors
certes on a toujours un effet général
qui est que des niveaux de dette plus
élevée sont associés à des croissance
légèrement plus faible mais le message
central le seuil fatidique de 90%
disparaît complètement
alors que rappelons le un ce seuil un
peu magique à semble-t-il été largement
évoquées pour justifier des politiques
d'austérité aux états unis et en europe
à cause d'une erreur excellent stupide
qu'il a fallu 3 ans pour débusquer alors
au passage les deux économistes de
harvard
évidemment à peine reconnu leur erreur
du bout des lèvres en disant que ça
changeait pas leurs conclusions
cette histoire semblant tellement
incroyable j'ai voulu creuser un peu les
chiffres pour voir ce qu'il y avait
derrière ont déjà j'ai lu l'article
d'origine il est assez court ça se lit
bien et sans être un expert en
économétrie je les trouvais étonnamment
pauvre sur le plan statistique il ya
juste des moyennes même pas mention d'un
écart type et je parle même pas d'un
test statistique pour savoir si c'est
significatif quand on connaît les
standards de publication en la matière
il compris en sciences économiques
ça m'a un peu surpris je me suis demandé
comment ça avait pu être publiée dans ce
qui est quasiment la revue de référence
en économie et j'ai fini par trouver la
réponse cet article n'a pas suivi le
processus habituel celui de l'évaluation
par les pairs alors j'ai parlé de ce
concept dans ma vidéo sur comment lire
une étude
quand des chercheurs de n'importe quelle
discipline un écrivain articles
scientifiques pour rapporter leur
découverte cet article est normalement
soumis à une relecture par d'autres
chercheurs du domaine dont le travail
est de vérifier que l'article respecte
notamment les exigences de qualité pour
être publié mais manifestement pour le
numéro de l'american economic review
dans laquelle cet article est paru
il n'y a pas eu de processus formalisé
de relecture par les pairs en gros on a
fait confiance aux auteurs sur la base
de leur pedigree pour comprendre mieux
ce qui se cachait derrière ces
croissances moyennes calculées par les
uns et les autres
eh ben j'ai voulu moi même voir les
données de mes propres yeux et je vais
vous montrer quelques analyses simples
qu'on peut faire alors les données sont
disponibles je vous mettrais liés en
descriptions et j'ai ici un tableau avec
pour chaque ligne un pays une année et
les deux valeurs correspondantes de
dette et de croissance en pourcentage du
pib
il ya environ 1200 lignes on a une
soixantaine d'années pour chacun des
vingt pays
pour commencer on peut déjà faire tout
simplement un graphique qui montre la
croissance en fonction de la dette pour
chacune de ces lignes de données
après ce qu'on obtient on peut zoomer un
peu sur la zone qui nous intéresse mais
ce qu'on voit c'est que globalement bas
c'est le bordel il y en a partout très
loin d'un lien mécanique automatique
absolue entre la dette et la croissance
et ça ça n'a rien de choquant c'est
normal la croissance d'un pays dépend de
tout un tas de facteurs pas seulement le
niveau de la dette mais du coup présenté
juste des moyennes par tranches sans
évoquer la 10
ce sont des données eh bien ça donne
l'impression que le lien est beaucoup
plus fort qu'il ne l'est réellement
alors malgré tout en regardant bien le
graphique on peut deviner un petit effet
avec un peu moins de croissance pour les
dettes plus élevé si on veut quantifier
ça a plus précisément on peut faire par
exemple une analyse de régression
linéaire c'est très simple et on trouve
le résultat suivant il ya en effet un
lien c'est un lien significatif
statistiquement c'est pas juste dû au
hasard et le coefficient montrent que
10% de dette en plus est associé en
moyenne à 0 18% de croissance en moins
donc l'effet moyens semblent exister
c'est une corrélation on ne sait pas a
priori s'il y a qu alité dans un sens
dans l'autre ou si c'est plus compliqué
mais un point important c'est que cet
effet n'explique qu'une toute petite
partie de la croissance
pour quantifier ça on parle de la
variance expliqué c'est à dire quelle
proportion de la variabilité des données
est expliquée par notre facteur ici la
dette
c'est le fameux air carré que les gens
utilisent parfois à tort et à travers
dans excel
ici le r carey est de 0,04
c'est pas beaucoup ça veut dire que le
facteur dette explique seulement 4 % de
la variabilité de la croissance alors on
peut essayer d'aller plus loin et
chercher d'éventuels effets non
linéaires et ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
n'ya pas du tout de seuil fatidique ni à
90% ni ailleurs si on a un petit truc
c'est peut-être plutôt autour de 30 40 %
où on a un léger changement quand on
peut même calculé que si on se limite
aux données entre 30 et 150 % de dette
le lien entre croissance et dette
pourrait disparaître complètement
bref on pourrait s'amuser longtemps à
faire des analyses avec ces données je
vais m'arrêter là ça n'est pas mon
domaine d expertise et d'autres l'ont
évidemment fait depuis de façon carrée
mais un dernier calcul quand même
évidemment si je découpe mes données en
quatre groupes de dette comme dans
l'article et que je calcule les moyennes
je retrouve les chiffres de l'article
corrigé par les chercheurs de
l'université du massachussetts bonne
nouvelle et avec ça je veux illustrer un
truc crucial qui ne concerne pas
seulement la recherche en économie c'est
l'importance pour les chercheurs de
publier les données complètes et les
codes de leur analyse dans plusieurs
disciplines scientifiques
on a assisté ces derniers temps à ce
qu'on appelle une crise de
reproductibilité
c'est à dire que certaines découvertes
publiées par des chercheurs
n'arrive pas à être répliquée répété par
d'autres chercheurs du domaine donc
forcément ça jette un doute sur les
conclusions initiales et on comprend que
dans certains cas ça puisse être
difficile de reproduire correctement une
expérience qui peuvent être longues
coûteuses délicate mais quand il s'agit
de résultats obtenus par un calcul
numérique
une analyse de données alors il ne
devrait y avoir aucune excuse
n'importe quel chercheurs du domaine
devraient pouvoir accéder au code aux
données pour vérifier lui-même que tout
est correct et on mettrai pas trois ans
à se rendre compte que l'un des articles
les plus influents du domaine est faux à
cause d'une formule excellent mal tapé
alors ce qui entre nous peut arriver à
tout le monde d'où l'importance de tous
ces systèmes de vérification
alors pour modérer un peu cette
conclusion sur le fait que peut-être
l'austérité financière aurait été causé
par une forme l'excellent on peut quand
même observer deux choses la première
c'est que l'erreur excellent n'est pas
ce qui a le plus biaiser les conclusions
de l'article d'origine
quand on regarde dans le détail on
remarque que c'est surtout d'une part
leur façon bizarre de faire les moyennes
et d'autre part l'exclusion apparemment
injustifiée de certaines données qui
semblait pourtant complètement
pertinente
la deuxième observation c'est qu'on peut
se demander quelle influence arrêt elle
a eu l'article d'origine sur le
déploiement des politiques d'austérité
face à la crise bien qu'il ait été
mentionné plusieurs fois comme
justification par des décideurs
politiques influents on peut imaginer
que si l'article n'avait pas existé
eh bien ces décideurs auraient trouvé
d'autres arguments pour justifier leur
position biais de confirmation c'est
classique mais bon à la fin si cette
histoire pouvait nous permettre
d'avancer vers une recherche
scientifique plus transparents et
reproductible ce serait déjà pas mal
surtout quand des conclusions
scientifiques sont utilisés pour guider
l'action politique
et oui toute référence à la situation
actuelle est bien sûr parfaitement vous
voilà c'est tout pour cette épisode un
peu inhabituel pour ceux que ça
intéresse je partage évidemment les
données et le code de l'année
en description c'est la moindre des
choses abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça
pour ne rien rater les actualités de la
chaîne c'est sur facebook et twitter et
on se retrouve prochainement pour de
nouvelles vidéos
à bientôt
[Musique]